carl's in destin florida hi carl welcome
to the ramsay show what's up
gentlemen thanks for taking my call i
have a unique situation here
um i'm 64. my wife is 65.
we have uh three properties two are
rentals
um we have no mortgages no car payments
no anything
good for you all the rams in the world
started many years ago paying off the
mortgage whatever i got in a rental i
put directly on the mortgage directly on
the mortgage
we also have 401ks my question is at
this age
should i continue to buy properties and
invest or just leave the money sit in
the bank or what should i do
what do you want to do i don't know
i feel like i should be productive and
continue
making money okay you're only 64. i'm
60. i'm not signing up for death right
now
so yeah what does productive mean to you
and i i'm asking this question carl not
from productive with your investments
because you've been very very smart
financially
i mean at 64 the fact that you're free
and can do anything
realistically what does productivity
mean to you
uh to me it means just you know being a
wage earner i'm retired now i'm not
earning
um any major wages you know you know in
the two three hundred
thousand dollar field but um i i just
really not sure i i see your net worth
it sounds like to me your net worth's
over 2 million
approximately yeah good guess almost
like i've done this before
okay so the uh uh way to go
beautiful job um so now you've landed on
the
island of paradise now what do we do so
if i'm you number one yes i'm going to
continue to invest in real estate and
i'm going to pay cash for whatever i buy
as i go we're not going back into debt
but i think you have some fun with that
i think you've had a good run with
property you like
property um you know if you told me you
hate being a landlord then probably
that's not the plan that's not the
definition of productivity as being in
real estate
but it's something that's at your
fingertips that you already have some
knowledge of
you feel good about but no we're not
signing up for coasting into retire or
coasting into death
at 64. we're going to sign up for
continuing to plow the field
the second thing i'll challenge you on
is a ken coleman challenge
and that is won't you back up and
whiteboard this thing for a minute and
go
crap if i could do anything i wanted to
do with the next 15 to 20 years what
would i do yeah because you know colonel
sanders never fried any chicken till he
was 64.
that's right oh and that just happens to
be carl's age as i recall
here so carl that's what i listen you
don't need to be a wage earner anymore
what work do you want to do let me put
it this way what contribution would you
like to give
as dave just said over the next five ten
years you want fried chicken all over
the world with your face on it i don't
know
i doubt that but you know you know what
what is the thing man what's the thing
you're truly at a place where you can do
that this is where most people want to
end up
yeah absolutely well done sir yeah so
proud of you
very very